for helen roberts public health nurse
it began like any other case a school
referral
an eight-year-old named george hargrove
who needed an eye check
hardly a relaxed type this mrs hargrove
she's young and she's troubled
but she says george already has an eye
appointment and that's all that matters
or is that really all
where you as a public health nurse are
concerned
now who might this young man be
could he have anything to do with his
mother's warn
weary discouraged look
don't worry mrs hargrove all children
fall sometimes
only mrs hargrove doesn't seem to see it
that way
mrs hargrove is tired and heart sick
she's exhausted all her own resources
don't expect him to say anything miss
roberts he can't talk
and that flashlight
if you're trying to make some kind of
test or something you're just wasting
your time
mark
well he's awfully slow about everything
it's terrible for mrs hargrove watching
him
hearing the things people say
but she still can't believe he's really
hopeless
because you see
she loves her little son
if only she could see a little progress
if only he could learn even the simplest
things like how to dress himself
hope
learning
progress
that's where you come in miss roberts
from you mrs hargrove can learn the
importance of having mark tested
diagnosed
evaluated
finding out how much he's able to learn
she needs your emotional support
your guidance
need you to help her understand how much
patience
and love
and ingenuity
and effort
go into teaching a [ __ ] child
so you're the one to show her how to
help her child to learn you helen
roberts
public health nurse
but that's all a long term project
and right now you've a child health
record entry to make
detailed observations of behavior to
note
two you'll have to arrange a referral on
this case through proper channels
draw on your knowledge of state and
community resources for care of the
mentally [ __ ]
see to it that mark and his parents get
all available help in dealing with their
problem
ordinarily each nurse will have at least
a few [ __ ] children in her caseload
so sooner or later you'll be working
with a [ __ ] child
often the startled pattern is a good
indicator check further when a child
doesn't react to a sudden noise
a normal child ordinarily shows a marked
response
two
a normal child may be expected to track
bright objects with his eyes at an early
age
he doesn't sit passive like this baby
such simple tests as these you already
know many of them out of your training
and experience
they all help you to tell the normal
child from the [ __ ]
when a five-year-old fails to work a
two-year level puzzle
it may indicate retardation
a six-year-old should be able to talk
intelligibly
if he can't
the problem may be a speech defect
or it may be retardation
on the other hand a mother may claim
that her child is a behavior problem and
try to hide the fact that he's slow or
emotionally disturbed
in either case as in all such situations
your first step is to call the case to
medical attention
this case finding is one of the nurses
biggest jobs where mental retardation is
concerned because retardation has many
many causes
brain injury
mongolism
cretinism
galectosemia
prenatal factors
familial and dozens of others
with early diagnosis some cases can be
helped medically but all parents can be
helped to help their youngsters to
develop the skills and graces they need
to live acceptably with others at their
level of readiness
take feeding
often [ __ ] children use a four
finger grip having trouble handling a
spoon
opposition of the thumb hasn't yet
developed
sometimes a bent spoon with a padded
handle helps it's easier for the child
to use than one that's straight
put his hand in position to grip
properly
at first of course the child may reject
the bent spoon
so you have to impress the mother with
the necessity for patience
first you show the mother how to proceed
then let her show the child
no luck
then go back to the old spoon and try to
teach the child to grip it with his fist
sometimes the answer's finger feeding
teaching the child to drink from a glass
helps too
but do limit yourself to showing the
mother what to do
let her teach the child
if the child rejects one drink offer him
another
for change may help to overcome his
negative attitude
repetition
relaxation and routine
these are the three r's of the [ __ ]
together they add up to the kind of help
that counts
toilet problems take the child to the
bathroom on schedule
and there'll be fewer accidents
for heaven's sake leave a lady some
privacy
oftentimes play can serve a constructive
purpose
to that end you carry various items for
testing and stimulation in your purse
a rattle a shiny pencil
a flashlight
keys that jingle
you see we all need reasons for doing
things
so you give young tom a reason to crawl
children learn by playing with simple
household articles they enjoy it too
this is more than just clipping
clothespins to a can
this is how ronald learns to coordinate
using familiar objects in a real life
situation
practical jobs help too
as the child masters a skill
she grows in pride achievement and
usefulness
a higher level [ __ ] child can become
independent and self-supporting
social graces are another asset many
[ __ ] children can acquire
the trick is to make a game of it
that way the child learns and has fun at
the same time
and so it goes in home after home but
it's not always the [ __ ] child who
claims your attention
most parents worry about his brothers
and sisters too
what effect does the [ __ ] child have
on them
what will happen in the future
as a nurse
you need to give the family emotional
support
help the parents to accept the situation
realistically
build their self-confidence so that they
can talk frankly and honestly to their
children
every time you show a [ __ ] child
genuine love and affection
you help the mother to become more
accepting
should the child be placed in an
institution
some youngsters will require such
custodial care but often parents don't
want to give up their child
and even when the decision is made
it may take months or years to find a
place
in the meanwhile
the family can continue to give loving
care and help him to learn what he can
a physician will discuss the factors
involved in custodial care as well as
care at home
as nurse it's your job to help the
[ __ ] child's parents to understand
through you
they can come to see the institution and
its function in a truer light
you can explain how their child may lead
a better fuller less complicated life in
a modern public or private school for
the [ __ ]
each [ __ ] child needs a special type
of education geared to his mental age
starting him to school before he's
mentally old enough
may cause emotional disturbance
it helps too
when you introduce families to their
local council of parents for mentally
[ __ ] children
give them a chance to discover that they
are not alone
but others share their problem equally
important you're not alone either
working together you and the family
physician can screen many retardation
cases for of course it helps if you have
a psychologist available to assist you
in mark's situation miss robert's first
step is to discuss the case with a
hargross physician
the community is one of the fortunate
few where there's a first class clinic
available
so the physician refers mark hargrove's
case there
here psychologists evaluate the mental
ability of each child
assist in planning for the youngster's
present
and his future
a child development specialist checks
educational and social abilities
and counsel's parents
physical therapists investigate muscle
development and physical coordination
speech therapists evaluate speech and
hearing abilities
recommend therapy when indicated
occupational therapists give practical
training in everyday tasks
the social worker studies family
relationships and helps the family use
community resources according to their
needs
physicians weigh each individual case
and diagnose it
make decisions
consider treatment
intake clinics consult with the parents
and make a preliminary investigation of
the case
all these contacts tie together even
more tightly at staff meetings
when the time comes to staff mark
hargrove
miss roberts contributes information and
opinion
helps with the evaluation
raises the question of mark's readiness
from a developmental standpoint
is he really able to dress himself at
this time
so later the physician summarizes the
evaluation for miss roberts
advises her as to how to proceed
a meeting between the physician and mr
and mrs hargrove
gives them a clear picture of the
medical and emotional aspects of mark's
case
it's important that both father and
mother be present
the social worker helps them understand
the broader implications of the
situation
the public health nurse in turn has
continuing contact with the total family
so miss roberts decides to work on
mark's dressing problem with repetition
relaxation and routine
she helps mrs hargrove set up a pattern
for mark to follow pants shirt
socks
shoes
let him put them on in that order every
time
pants with boxer type waste
are easiest for a child to handle
she shows mrs hargrove how to teach mark
to put on his shirt and button it
putting on a sock involves definite
procedures
it's best to roll it to the toe
and work it up the foot clear past the
heel
the white stripe here goes right across
the toes
shoes come next
but learning's a slow process for mark
so patience is ever the watch word
the same patience and organized effort
that helps her in all her work
by adhering to such organized procedures
the nurse finds new cases she uses all
available facilities
she makes proper referrals
she helps with case evaluation
she gives emotional support to anxious
parents
above all
she looks for signs of readiness in the
child
shows his parents how to help him learn
how long will that learning take
how far can he go
nobody knows
the important thing is to start where he
is and then keep trying
don't force
go at the child's pace
don't push
your guides are the small goals
in learning to dress himself
mark is achieving such a goal
it's one of the few advances he'll ever
know perhaps
but is an important one in making life
easier for him and those about him
his mother's happy that her child has
shown the ability to learn
at least a little
and with that knowledge comes new hope
for his mastery of other living skills
and social graces
his world has changed
foreign
and our miss robert
where does she stand
she and every other public health nurse
who's helped a family meet this problem
could it be
that she feels an even greater
satisfaction than the mother
but in this small triumph
she sees the proof that her work is
truly worthwhile
the justification for all her pride in
her profession
the fulfillment of her ideal of service
good questions those aren't they
even though for public health nurses
they don't need any answers
you